Bienvenidos a este especial sobre
Colombia y su giro a la izquierda nos
centramos en una pregunta se resolverán
los problemas históricos el 7 de agosto
Gustavo Petro un ex guerrillero y
Francia Márquez una líderesa
medioambiental afrodescendiente fueron
proclamados presidente y vicepresidenta
es el primer ejecutivo de izquierda de
la historia del país y desde su campaña
y hasta su programa de gobierno el
énfasis se ha centrado en lograr los
cambios estructurales que Colombia
demanda empezamos en este programa nos
centraremos en tres de los principales
objetivos son las economías ilícitas de
las que dependen miles de personas en el
país el problema de tierras para un
estado que nunca ha realizado una
reforma agraria y cómo no los grupos
armados con el gran objetivo de Gustavo
Petro puesto en el desarme de la
guerrilla activa más antigua de América
Latina el ejército de liberación
nacional en el siguiente informe hacemos
un repaso a esta historia de violencia
de Colombia a la conversión más de 60
años de violencia en Colombia comenzaron
Los bandoleros campesinos y derivaron en
grupos armados de toda ideología
disputas con gran participación del
estado con el control de tierra de telón
de fondo para explotar economías
ilegales pero también para el control
social e incluso favoreciendo a grandes
multinacionales la comisión de la verdad
en su informe final de 2022 sitúa El
número de víctimas en 8 millones
775.884 personas y el de homicidios en
450.000-664 donde los grupos
paramilitares fueron los más sangrientos
seguidos por guerrilleros y finalmente
el estado el narcotráfico puso a
Colombia en el mapa mundial
Especialmente con la figura de Pablo
Escobar
alrededor de las economías ilegales
creció el paramilitarismo que surgió
para combatir a las guerrillas y terminó
siendo apoyado por el estado su mayor
proyecto fueron las autodefensas Unidas
de Colombia desmovilizadas en 2006
también a lo largo de las décadas hubo
múltiples guerrillas de izquierda como
el m-19 donde militó el presidente
Gustavo Petro de tinte socialdemócratas
y desmovilizada en 1990 las fuerzas
armadas revolucionarias de Colombia
desmovilizadas en 2017 fueron la primera
y más numerosa guerrilla de toda América
Latina llegando a controlar vastos
territorios del país queda el eln la
última guerrilla de los años 60 activa
en América Latina ya en negociaciones
con un gobierno que además Busca una paz
total con todo tipo de grupos disidentes
un reto mayúsculo después de que en el
tercer trimestre del año y primero del
gobierno del izquierdista Gustavo Petro
los asesinatos a líderes sociales
crecieran un 64% respecto a 2021 para
ampliar sobre estas negociaciones
hablamos con Danilo Rueda alto
comisionado para la paz de Colombia nos
Explica qué es la paz total Colombia
Lleva más de 70 años de conflicto
político y otros conflictos armados La
Apuesta de la paz integral de La Paz
total es tratar de cerrar todos estos
ciclos de violencias en una puesta
ambiciosa que posibilite el cierre de
las violencias políticas y el cierre de
violencias criminales que ocurren en
Colombia unos 200 líderes sociales han
sido asesinados en 2022 en Colombia para
Danilo Rueda el panorama puede cambiar
en 2023 todavía no ha impactado ceses
bilaterales ni multilaterales del pero
vamos avanzando en esa materia y quizás
las mesas y los escenarios de
conversaciones que se aproximan en las
próximas semanas tengan ya un escenario
de distensión más evidente que permita
Mostrar los resultados específicos en
distensión a la población y en el cese
de acciones violentas de carácter letal
los grupos armados aprovecharon su
control sobre partes del territorio
colombiano para impulsar las economías
ilícitas en este primer mapa vemos el
panorama de cultivos de Coca Colombia es
el mayor productor de cocaína del mundo
la ONU en su último informe situó los
cultivos en 204.000 hectáreas un récord
histórico los principales centros de
producción están en el suroccidente del
país en el norte de Antioquia y en el
catatumbo son zonas con presencia de
grupos armados igual que las rutas de
salida de la mercancía el segundo mapa
está dedicado a la deforestación en los
últimos 21 años Colombia ha perdido 3
millones de hectáreas y como muestra
este mapa desde 2015 a 2019 el problema
se ha agravado especialmente después del
acuerdo de paz entre el estado y las
FARC la guerrilla controlaba grandes
extensiones de territorio con una
importante masa forestal y tras su
desarme esas zonas pasaron a manos de
otros grupos armados y la deforestación
se disparó por último Este es un mapa
centrado en la minería de oro según la
ONU más del 60% de este tipo de minería
es ilegal como se puede ver en el mapa
se concentra especialmente en la
Cordillera occidental hecho que también
ha grabado la violencia en esos
territorios además de un impacto
medioambiental con la contaminación de
los ríos debido al uso del mercurio para
ampliar sobre este tema tenemos en
nuestro plato de France 24 a Estefanía
asilo directora investigadora del centro
de pensamiento desde la amazonía
colombiana a la orilla del río Estefanía
Muchas gracias por estar en 34 No
gracias a ti Gustavo Petro habla del
fracaso en la lucha contra las drogas
Por qué es un error perseguir la hoja de
Coca hay que pensar primero esto como un
mercado agroexportador no este es el
mercado agroexportador más importante de
Colombia y además donde trabajan por lo
menos 400.000 personas es importante
tener en cuenta que hay una falacia de
la falacia de la lucha contra las drogas
por un lado nos hacen creer que es un
mercado que se puede destruir son 20
millones de consumidores y la lucha
contra las drogas nos ha hecho creer que
se puede desaparecer Pero por otro lado
realmente lo que ha ocurrido como tú has
mostrado es que ha significado la
expansión minero energética de por
ejemplo la amazonía colombiana lo que
detona la lucha contra las drogas es un
control más específico de las
multinacional sobre sectores y
territorios poblaciones geoestratégicas
entonces por eso hablamos de la falacia
de la lucha contra las drogas si decimos
que fracasó fracasó porque no acabó ese
mercado no atacar la oferta no acabó ese
mercado pero por el otro lado si decimos
que si fracasó con la falacia pues no
fracasó Por qué instaló la digamos la
explotación extractivista en los
territorios pero en este escenario los
campesinos y campesinas pues han sido
las víctimas principales de este las
economías ilegales tienen peso en el pib
de la economía colombiana Cómo hacer una
transición sin afectar a miles de
familias sí es fundamental es imposible
que no se vayan a afectar primero porque
en este momento Este mercado
agroexportador hace que las personas que
menos ganan son las que más violencia
reciben los campesinos y los que más
ganan son los que más violencia ejercen
o menos reciben Entonces el problema es
que necesitamos a cambiar esa ecuación
Porque si seguimos así pues estamos
generando una crisis humanitaria
impresionante Entonces es necesario
transitar hacia algo El problema es que
los intentos de transitar hacia la
legalidad pues han fracasado la
sustitución y la erradicación han sido
causantes de crisis económicas profundas
en los territorios y no han servido y
para terminar brevemente Estefanía esos
grupos armados también dependen de esas
economías ilícitas sí absolutamente pero
yo quiero ir más allá de así como de la
falacia de la lucha contra las drogas de
la falacia de las rutas no Esto no es
solo un tema de una pelea de rutas es un
tema de que por supuesto necesitan
dinero para armarse pero necesitan
también hombres entonces necesitamos que
los hombres y mujeres no encuentren en
la guerra un lugar pero pues la
exclusión la destrucción de la vida
cotidiana campesina y rural en el país
hace que hayan siempre hombres queriendo
armarse eso es un elemento fundamental y
tercero la discusión sobre
qué ocurre con las erradicaciones qué
ocurre con la deforestación y la gente
buscando tierras hay todavía una
carencia de
desarrollo rural no y hay mucha
violencia ejercida aún que es necesario
evitar mientras siga habiendo violencia
mientras siga habiendo pobreza y
desarrollo
subdesarrollo en las regiones Pues
siempre va a haber hombres y mujeres con
fusiles para la guerra para pues
legitimar cualquier proyecto político
Muchas gracias Estefanía por estar aquí
en France 24 Gracias a ti
economía ilícitas grupos armados y en
medio la tierra
muchas hectáreas fueron despojadas
durante el conflicto la oficina de
restitución de tierras del Ministerio de
agricultura trata de devolverlas a sus
dueños el director es Giovanni julen un
indígena Nasa en el siguiente reportaje
le acompañamos hasta el resguardo de
huellas en Santander de quilichao su
lugar de nacimiento es la presentación
oficial ante su gente veamos
Giovanni Julie vuelve al Cabildo de su
resguardo indígena de la etnia NASA está
en el municipio de caloto en el
suroccidente de Colombia Saludos abrazos
y compromisos ya Giovanni conoce el
proceso en lugar de un Regreso como
líder indígena ahora lo hace del otro
lado el tema de lo que nos corresponde a
nosotros como entidades el tema de la
restitución es el nuevo director de
restitución de tierras la agencia del
gobierno encargada de devolver las
hectáreas despojadas a las víctimas del
conflicto colombiano
ven en nosotros la esperanza de hacer
esos cambios estructurales de la
política del Estado y a la vez
preocupado porque por supuesto desde la
institucionalidad hay muchas
frustraciones es que llueve mucho allá
Giovanni ahora del frío de Bogotá la
capital antes del nombramiento siempre
estuvo en su territorio Allí se
convirtió en un importante líder del
cric uno de los principales movimientos
indígenas de Colombia la UNESCO maestro
de la sabiduría
entre múltiples compromisos ha vuelto
para presentarse como director ante su
gente
que todavía hay
que ha renacido la esperanza Colombia
sobre la expectativa es muy grande desde
la prensa local y hasta las comunidades
indígenas afrodescendientes y campesinas
Por fin se ven representados tras ser
nombrado por Gustavo Petro el primer
presidente de izquierdas de la historia
de Colombia debe ser es la ciudadanía la
gente organizada la que debe de
propiciar esos cambios
Giovanni Julie fue víctima del conflicto
el departamento del cauca es uno de los
más disputados hay numerosos cultivos de
coca y es un lugar de tránsito de
economías ilegales los indígenas quedan
en medio Tal vez es la primera vez en la
historia que nosotros podemos tener el
director de la unidad de restitución en
nuestro territorio que vamos a seguir
restituyendo la tierra para armonizar la
vida restitución de tierras entró en
funcionamiento en 2012 con la ley de
víctimas
años después solo se han restituido un
10% de seis millones de hectáreas en la
próxima década deberán restituir un 90%
Bueno listo los sectores
tradicionalmente excluidos están
ilusionados con la posibilidad de
resolver estas problemáticas históricas
pero en la sociedad también surgen
interrogantes se pueden resolver en
cuatro años de gobierno es la primera
piedra de un nuevo futuro o directamente
este giro a la izquierda no funcionará
lo Seguiremos de cerca en France 24
hasta aquí el especial Muchas gracias
por acompañarnos Pueden seguir más
contenidos como este enfrán 34 y France
24.com
[Música]